Die Kugel wird mit der Hand geschnitten.
Zeug strendet womit ich nicht wirklich
Okay, der Dauerbrenner
Lindemann, okay
Ja gut, wenn Ransch, Gendarm natürlich, wenn ich diese, wenn ich diese Trends schon lese, da weiß ich wieder, ich muss ganz schnell weg
von, von Twitter Deutschland
So und jetzt, passt mal auf, jetzt gehe ich mal auf Twitter, bei mir, ich muss mal hier drauf, pass mal auf
Trends Andorra. Ich zeige euch mal mein Screenshot von meinem Twitter.
Trends Andorra.
So sieht das bei mir aus.
So und jetzt, und jetzt seriously.
Was ist besser?
Ups.
Was ist euch lieber?
Wenn ihr euch diesen ganzen Müll hier durchlesen müsst in Twitter-Deutschland
oder wenn ihr in Andorra wohnt.
Also welcher Trend ist euch lieber davon?
Also ich bleib in Andorra auf jeden Fall.
Weil ich einer von denen bin, die eigentlich einfach nur ihre Ruhe haben wollen
und nicht permanent von der Seite irgendwie irgendeinen Shit mitkriegen wollen.
Wie geht es der Katze? Warum hat die einen verbannt?
Ist nichts schlimmes. Also wahrscheinlich meinst du das hier.
Du meinst wahrscheinlich das hier. Katze mit Verband.
Ist nichts schlimmes. Die Katze musste gestern Blut abnehmen.
Beim Arzt, beim Tierarzt.
Und danach kriegt man so nen Klebeding drum. Selbsthaftenden Verband.
Die musste Blut abnehmen, als Kontrolle. Wir waren nämlich vor ein paar Wochen schon beim Tierarzt.
Und Chico ist, weil Chico ist alt, die ist glaube ich so 13 oder so jetzt.
Die hat Schilddrüsen-Überfunktion.
Und die Nierenblutwerte sind auch nicht so tolle, aber das ist im Alter fast normal.
Du kannst nirgends was in der Richtung haben und die kriegt jetzt seit, ich glaub, drei Wochen
kriegt die für die Niere so Flüssigkeit übers Futter, das futtert sie tatsächlich auch ganz
also ohne Probleme weiter und morgens und abends kriegt sie so ein bisschen Süßkram, da ist Schildkrüsen-Medikament drin
und das hat richtig was gebracht, also warum ich mit Chico überhaupt zum Arzt bin
lag daran
Also
Ich meine, ihr seht es hier vielleicht so, das hier hinten ist ein Klo und so. Chico ist jetzt eine relativ kleine Katze, ja.
Und die war, als ich die geholt habe aus dem Tierheim, war Chico auch recht dick.
Ich kann euch jetzt kein Foto zeigen, aber na doch, hier unten rechts, hier unten rechts sieht man es noch ein bisschen.
Aber nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich gut. Na also, als ich die aus dem Tierheim geholt habe, hat die ungefähr
5,2 Kilo oder so gewogen. Da war die recht, recht Chonker mäßig.
Und die hat jetzt aber die letzten Jahre über kontinuierlich ein bisschen abgenommen, hauptsächlich deswegen, weil die bei mir mehr nasses Futter kriegt als Trockenfutter.
Und früher hat die halt so Trockenfutter wie Chips gefressen quasi.
Äh, mir ist langweilig, ich geh Trockenfutter fressen.
Aber mir kriegt die jetzt ordentliches Nassfutter, wenn sie es denn frisst.
Manchmal kriegt sie auch übelsten Lidl-Scheiß, weil sie ihn am liebsten frisst, aber okay.
Und seitdem hat die immer ein bisschen abgenommen.
ist jetzt aber seit seit bestimmt einem Jahr oder so mehr oder weniger stabil gewesen so auf
Ja, 3,7 Kilo oder sowas, was für, was für Chico echt von der Größe und so ein ganz gutes Gewicht ist
und die hat jetzt
in einem Monat
500 Gramm abgenommen oder in eineinhalb Monaten 500 Gramm, das ist, das ist extrem viel
Also es heißt rein rechnerisch ist die Katze, gibt sie, ist die Katze nicht, hat sich aufgelöst
Quasi in, äh, 6 Monaten oder so.
So, und, dass das nicht so weiter geht,
so weiter gehen kann, ist natürlich klar.
Deswegen war ich mit Chico beim Doktor
und die haben Blut abgenommen
und haben festgestellt,
dass die, äh, bisschen, bisschen schlechte Nierenwerte hat
und vor allem hat die Schilddrüsen-Über-Überfunktion
als fuck, also, keine Ahnung.
Wenn der Grenzwert irgendwie 10 ist,
hatte, hatte, hatte Chico 50 oder so, ja?
oder so. Ja, die hatte ziemlich, ziemlich hohe Werte und die kriegt jetzt morgens und abends
Ja, wir wiegen die regelmäßig. Die kriegt jetzt morgens und abends, kriegt hier so ein bisschen Süßkram, da ist Schilddrüsen-Medikament drin und seitdem sie das kriegt
Also die kriegt das jetzt seit drei Wochen oder so, die hat jetzt sogar schon wieder 40 Gramm zugenommen
Und ist insgesamt auch viel besser drauf, ja
Ich hab das schon gemerkt, so die letzten 1-2 Monate ist sie so richtig antriebslos rumgeschlichen die ganze Zeit.
Ich mein, Chico ist alt, Chico pennt auch gefühlt 90% des Tages, das ist normal.
Aber wenn die wach ist, ist sie sonst immer ganz fit gewesen.
Und da hat sie auch die ganze Zeit so übelst rumgeschlichen nur noch.
Und ja, das scheint aber wirklich das Problem gewesen zu sein.
Weil da geht's jetzt deutlich besser seitdem die den Kram kriegt.
Und da war ich gestern mit der Katz beim Tierarzt
Und da haben wir nochmal zur Kontrolle Blut abgenommen
So, und das abnehmen lassen
Tierarzt wollte mich eigentlich gestern anrufen, haben sie vergessen und heute auch nicht
Also morgen muss ich ja mal anrufen, wie jetzt die neuen Blutwerte sind von der Katz
Das nervt mich auch immer sowas
Wie wenn irgendjemand sagt, ah wir melden uns
Normalerweise frage ich dann immer bei solchen Sachen
Ja, soll ich heute Abend nochmal anrufen oder irgendwie sowas
Und wenn es dann als Antwort heißt, ja, ja, wir melden uns heute Abend bei Ihnen und dann kommt nichts, das regt mich immer ein bisschen auf.
Ich meine, okay, die haben viel zu tun, das verstehe ich schon, ja, dann hätten sie zumindest mal heute noch anrufen können.
Oder die hätte irgendeine von ihren Helferinnen abkommandieren können, mal halt anzurufen und durchzugeben, was Sache ist.
Das finde ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Ich meine, ich verstehe ja, dass die viel zu tun haben, aber mich interessiert es ja halt, was mit der Katze ist.
Wie kamst du eigentlich zu... Das ist eine schnell beantwortete Frage.
Also was hat dich dazu gebracht, sie zu entscheiden, als eine andere?
Das ist tatsächlich relativ einfach zu erklären, wie ich zu Chico gekommen bin.
Also Chico habe ich aus dem Tierheim.
Bei uns hier in der Nähe, aus dem Tierheim.
Und...
Also das ist der... Daher habe ich Chico.
Warum ich, aber was du, was du wahrscheinlich wissen willst ist, warum ich ausgerechnet Chico genommen habe im Tierheim und nicht irgendeine andere?
Das ist, das ist auch tatsächlich recht einfach zu erklären und zwar
Wir machen das anders, ich zeig dir das mal kurz anhand, weil das man
So, also, ich hab hier ja mal ein Video gemacht, da sieht man ja alle meine Katzen.
So, hier sieht man Chico.
So, hier sieht man Chico auf dem Schrank, hier sieht man Chico sich streicheln, hier
sieht man Chico bei mir in den Armen beißen.
Guck mal, seht ihr das? Da war Chico noch eine ganze Ecke dicker, vor zwei Jahren.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man es richtig erkennt, aber da war noch ein bisschen mehr an Chico dran.
Ja, da war die noch eine ganze Ecke dicker vor zwei Jahren.
So, also wie ich zu Chico gekommen bin, ganz einfach.
Auf Chico, hüpf mal.
Ja, also, das hier ist die erste Katze, die ich hier im Haus hatte.
Die haben wir vom Nachbar damals, ich nenns mal, ich nenns mal, geerbt.
Der Nachbar ist damals gestorben und die Katze hat im Hof rumgestanden und gemauzt.
Und da hab ich der was zu essen gegeben und ein paar Tage später hat sie gesagt, soll
ich zieh jetzt bei euch ein.
Und dann ist sie drei Wochen nicht mehr aus dem Haus rausgegangen, weil sie Angst hatte, wir schmeißen sie wieder raus, wenn sie vor die Tür geht.
So, also das ist Original-Katz-FPS gewesen.
Die war halt auch schon alt.
Ja, so, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Und ein bisschen später, also als es Original-Katz-FPS dann irgendwann nicht mehr gab, bin ich ein Jahr später oder so ins Tierheim.
Und hab mir die hier ausgesucht, die nächste. Moment.
Die hier.
Die ist richtiger Chonker gewesen. Ola, Leute.
Die war größer als Chico, aber die war richtig dick.
Man sieht's ja hier, glaub ich, auch, ne?
Also an der war richtig was dran.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich's euch schon mal erzählt hab,
aber ihr seht, also die Katze, die ist schon...
Also die, die, die ist richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig Chonker.
Ähm, ratet mal.
Okay, ihr kommt nicht drauf, vielleicht hab ich's euch schon erzählt.
Wisst ihr, wie die hieß?
Das ist, glaub ich, so ziemlich der unpassendste Name für diese, für die dicke Katze hier überhaupt gewesen.
Die hieß Barbie.
Aber ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht.
Und die hat am liebsten, die hat am liebsten vorm Fernseher gehockt.
Also Barbie, Barbie hat am liebsten vom Fernsehen gehockt und hat sich so Eichhörnchen-Videos angeguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr eine Katze habt oder so.
Also Barbie stand total auf Eichhörnchen-Videos.
So, die Sache war die.
Jetzt ganz kurzer Sättge-Moment.
Also, hier steht ja auch, dass sie Barbie heißt.
Also wir haben die aus dem Tierheim geholt im Frühjahr.
Und eigentlich wusste man schon, dass sie krank ist.
Wir wussten nicht so genau, also das war auch mit ein Grund,
weil wir uns gedacht haben, ey guck mal, alte Katze, die wollen wir jetzt nicht im Tierheim sitzen lassen,
der geht's eh nicht mehr so gut, die haben wir mitgenommen.
Und die hat leider bloß noch ein Dreivierteljahr gelebt.
So, und daraufhin...
Moment, ja hier ist wieder Chico am Start.
So, und daraufhin, als sie gestorben ist, bin ich nochmal ins Tierheim gefahren und hab auch gesagt, ähm, ja, ähm, ich bin wieder auf der Suche nach einer Katze und da hab ich mit der gleichen Frau gesprochen, mit der ich mir auch damals Barbie ausgesucht hab.
Und ich glaube, die hatte ein bisschen ein schlechtes Gewissen, dass wir quasi eine Katze von ihr bekommen haben, die bloß noch dreiviertel Jahr gelebt hat.
Wobei die nicht wirklich was dafür konnte, man wusste das ja von Anfang an.
Und die hat uns angerufen dann, also wir haben ein bisschen geguckt und die hat uns dann ein paar Tage, nachdem wir im Tierheim waren, hat die uns angerufen.
Rufen hat gemeint es kam gerade eine ganz neue katze rein ganz furchtbar niedlich und lieb und sonst was
und
Die würde sie gerne möglichst schnell vermitteln weil die ist auch andere katzen und so überhaupt nicht gewöhnt und das wäre genau das richtige
Für uns und da sind wir dahin gefahren und dann saß dann halt
Saß dann halt Chico da
Guck mal da war es noch, da war es noch richtiger Chonker, hier guck dir, seht ihr das?
Seht ihr wie dick Chico mal war am Anfang?
Seht, guckt mal wie dick Chico gewesen ist!
Chico war mal richtig, guckt euch das mal an!
Chico war mal richtig dick!
An der war mal richtig was dran!
Ja, so und so bin ich zu Chico gekommen, weil die aus dem Tierheim angerufen hat, hier daheim, hat gemeint, es ist gerade hier perfekte Katze für euch reingekommen.
Und da sind wir hingegangen, haben uns Chico angeguckt, haben festgestellt, Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Also Chico hat wirklich, also die darf ja mittlerweile sogar raus auf die Terrasse, ja, da habe ich so einen Vorhang hin, dass die nicht rauskommt.
Und die hat Schiss vor allem, also wenn der Nachbar oder wenn von den Nachbarn einer aus dem Fenster guckt, ist die schon auf dem Weg zur Tür.
Oder noch, also was sie immer richtig schockt, die Nachbarin klopft manchmal Teppiche aus auf dem Balkon.
Das klopft dann immer so ein bisschen. Boah ey, da müsst ihr mal sehen, wie schnell die zur Tür rennt.
Die anderen zwei hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Also sowohl die Original Katze-FBS als auch Barbie hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt, wenn da draußen was war.
Ja, also, genau, Freigänger. Das hier schon immer, also war schon immer, seit Anfang an, Freigänger und Barbie auch.
Soweit ich weiß kam Barbie von irgendeinem tschechischen Bauernhof oder so ursprünglich.
Das heißt die weiß wie es draußen ist oder wusste wie es draußen ist.
Ja und Chico.
Wie dick die da noch gewesen ist.
Barbie hat gerne Eichhörnchen-Videos, Chico nicht.
Chico steht nicht so auf Videos.
auf Videos.
Ähm...
So, und Chico war eigentlich reine
Wohnungskatze, wurde uns gesagt.
Aber irgendwann
bin ich auf die Idee gekommen und hab mir so ein Netz
gekauft für die Terrasse.
Jetzt nicht so ein Balkonnetz,
sondern
sowas Spezielles.
Also nicht...
Schutznetze
24, keine Ahnung.
Also nicht sowas für
Balkon sondern ich weiß auch nicht mehr wo ich das bestellt habe zumindest
zumindest was ich gekauft habe ist folgendes ich habe ein Stahlseil gekauft
und ein ziemlich engmaschiges so geflechtetes Netz so und das Stahlseil
habe ich gespannt, habe ich halt zwei Haken in die Wand gemacht. Das Stahlseil habe ich gespannt vorne
am Eingang von der Terrasse lang, über dem Eingang von der Terrasse lang und da drüber habe ich dieses
das Netz gemacht. Also das ist kratz- und bissfest, das ist katzengetestet das Netz. Das habe ich da
drüber gemacht und jetzt kann man das, wenn man auf die Terrasse will, kann man das Netz einfach so
zur seite schieben oben über oft über dem über dem seil lang oder ansonsten
macht man es halt so ich habe dann unten also ein brett drauf gelegt sondern jetzt
kann chicco raus und quasi auf der gesamten terrasse sich austoben kann
aber nicht abhauen weil halt weil er hat ein netznetz drüber ist alter chicco
warst du mal dick das fällt mir ja jetzt erst auf meine güte chicco bist du mal
dick gewesen guckt euch das mal an hier guckt euch mal
mal das hier angegen. Guckt mal hier! Ich mein außer das hier noch der Bauch ein bisschen
hängt. Aber Leute! Mega Chonker Chico! Ziemlich dünne Chico! Guck mal hier, hier ist nix
mehr unten. Das ist eigentlich alles ganz ganz normal. Und hier ist richtige Kugel
am Start. Also hier ist Chico ja nochmal richtig pipo-fett. Die Chonkert, genau. So, genug
über meine Katze ausgelassen.
Ja, wie gesagt, habe ich euch gerade erklärt.
Du wirst erstaunt sein, das sind nicht die einzigen Tabs, hier habe ich noch Tabs und
hier habe ich auch noch Tabs.
Also guck mal, es reicht nicht, ich habe zwei.
Hier habe ich keinen, aber in meiner VM habe ich noch welche.
Deine Daten magst du, wenn man pfeift?
Also meine guckt da nur blöd, wenn man pfeift und so ein bisschen
Guckt sie mich an oder was willst du von mir?
Keine Ahnung
Bin ich mir nicht sicher
Man kann sich aber auch einfach gescheites Katzenfutter kaufen mit hohem Fleischanteil, das geht ja auch
Also ich hatte mal Katzenfutter
Ich weiß nicht mal von welchem Hersteller das ist. Das war 100%
Tunfisch und 100% Hähnchen.
Und wenn man das Katzen-, also normalerweise, ihr kennt das vielleicht,
normalerweise, wenn man Katzen- oder Hundefutter aufmacht,
so dieses, das Billigfutter, so was es vom Lidl und so gibt,
das, das stinkt übelst.
Okay, für uns, ich meine Katzen mögen das furchtbar geil finden oder so, das stinkt übelst.
So, und ich hab mal so ein, ich hab mal so ein, so ein, so ein Set gekauft,
Nee, das war, ich glaub, das war Thunfisch und Huhn oder irgendwie so ne komische Mischung, ne Thunfisch und Ente oder so.
Keine Ahnung, das war zumindest hochwertig, das hab ich aufgemacht
und das hat gerochen so wie, als könnte, also nicht, dass man's, dass man's machen sollte, ja?
Aber das hat gerochen wie, wenn ich vom Lidl irgendwie was gekauft hab, was ich jetzt gleich in die Pfanne hauen will und anbraten.
Also das, das hochwertig, gut, das hat auch ordentlich gekostet, 100% Thunfisch, 100% Hähnchen.
Das war kein billiges Kassenfutter.
Also das war quasi ungefähr so teuer wie wenn ich zum Lidl gehen würde oder zum EDK Fleisch theke und sage hier auf geht's ich will was bestellen.
Das hat aber auch so gerochen wie als könntest du es selbst essen.
Was wir natürlich nicht gemacht haben, aber das ist der riesen Unterschied zu einem billig Lidl Futter.
Ja, Katzen können halt richtig alt werden.
Ja so muss das sein.
9 Babys?
Dann will ich mal schnell gucken, dass die
dass die
Ratzfatz sterilisiert,
kastriert, was auch immer wird.
Weil ansonsten hast du öfters mal 9 Babys.
Willst du nach Chico?
Na klar!
Ich hatte jetzt 3 Stück, also
ich hoffe ja, Chico macht's noch ganz lange, ja?
Aber natürlich hol ich mir nach Chico
neue Katzen. Ich werd bis ich
in Rente gehe immer... Warum nicht?
Ich hatte, sogar wie ich klein war, fand ich Katzen schon super.
Warum soll ich mir keine neue mehr holen?
Ich werde mir auf jeden Fall eine neue holen.
Aber wie gesagt, also...
Ich gehe davon aus, Chico gibt es noch eine ganze Weile.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht hole ich ja auch Chico irgendwann nochmal eine zweite.
Eigentlich hat Chico... Also der Grund, warum ich keine zweite habe bei Chico ist...
Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Und Chico, das hat man im Tierheim, die haben das im Tierheim ausprobiert.
Die haben auch explizit gesagt, das ist tatsächlich eine Katze, die als Einzelkatze, die Einzelkatze sein will.
Normalerweise sagt man immer, Katzen sind viel zu langweilig alleine und sowas und es ist viel besser zu zweit.
Aber Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Und die hat, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ne?
Im Tierheim saß die in ihrem Käfig drinne und da war so eine kleine freche Babykatze, die da rumgeflitzt ist.
Die war, keine Ahnung, 10 cm groß oder so.
Das war, das war
Mini Katze, die da rumgeflitzt ist
und
Die ist dann irgendwann hochgeklettert und bei Chico in die Box gehüpft
Also in den Käfig gehüpft, dem Tier, wo Chico auch drin war. Die haben das, die haben das so gemacht irgendwie
Das, das irgendwie ab und zu mal am Tag wurde das alles aufgemacht, da konnten die Katzen ein bisschen
rumstelzen und so und Chico hat sich da, da schon nicht raus getraut und da ist diese zehn Zentimeter Babykatze, ja
in den in den Käfig von Chico gehüpft und was hat Chico gemacht? Also alle meine
anderen zwei hätten folgendes gemacht die hätten an der Babykatze geschnuppert
und hätten sich gedacht naja gut solange die nicht an mein Futter geht juckt's
mich nicht. Was Chico gemacht hat ist Chico ist auf die höchste Ebene in ihrem
Käfig gekrabbelt in ihren Korb rein und hat angefangen zu fauchen. Vorne zehn
Zentimeter Babykatze. Also Chico hat, ohne Schiss und ohne Spaß, Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Wenn ich zu schnell durch den Flur laufe, renze, die hat wirklich Schiss, gut bei mir hat sie sich jetzt mittlerweile schon dran gewöhnt, aber am
Anfang, also ich weiß nicht, was die mit der gemacht haben, wo die herkommt, aber Chico hat wirklich Schiss vor
vor allem. Leute, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, Chico hat Angst vor Flummis.
Normalerweise, also alle Katzen, die ich bisher hatte und kannte, fanden Flummis was ganz tolles.
Flummis ist das Beste.
Chico hat Angst vor Flummis.
Ich nehm den Flummi und werf den so nicht schnell, so langsam in Flur,
der duppt einmal auf der Flummi und Chico rennt in die entgegengesetzte Richtung weg.
Also Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Also ich kann mir das nur so erklären, dass wo die hergekommen ist, dass sie die nicht gut behandelt haben müssen, sonst würde ich nicht verstehen warum es da so steht.
Also das muss ich sagen, die haben uns Chico tatsächlich damals im Tierheim, die haben wirklich gesagt, das ist die Ausnahme,
Chico ist reine Hauskatze und Chico mag gar keine anderen Tiere und hat Angst vor anderen Tieren so.
Sollen wir... okay.
Aber ich muss sagen, seitdem ich Chico rauslasse auf die Terrasse, die darf ja schon ne Weile raus.
Ich hab euch das ja gerade erzählt, ich hab die Terrasse ja quasi so katzensicher gemacht, dass sie nicht abhauen kann.
Und ich hab eh mehrstufige Sicherung.
Ich hab das Netz an der Terrasse und der Hof selber ist auch nochmal halbwegs katzensicher.
So, und seitdem die raus darf auf die Terrasse, hab ich auch den Eindruck, ist Chico viel
besser drauf.
Also Chico ist so planlos, die wird sich verlaufen, wenn wir zurückfinden.
Sie ist bei mir genauso, also ohne Mist, seitdem Chico raus darf, die darf jetzt auch schon
Über ein Jahr darf die schon raus, das war letzten Sommer war das schon da, also wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, ne doch, ich glaub das haben wir sogar noch Anfang von Corona
Die darf schon, die darf schon zweieinhalb Jahre oder so raus
Und aber seitdem die raus darf ist Chico viel besser drauf, hab ich zumindest den Eindruck, ja
Und die mag mich mehr als vorher
Ich glaube, also was heißt die mag mich, die schleimt bei mir viel mehr rum als früher, die Katz
Ich glaube irgendwie, dass sie das schon kapiert hat, dass ich ihr das jetzt quasi so gemacht habe, dass sie raus kann.
Also sie checkt nicht, dass ich das umgebaut habe, dass sie raus kann, aber Chico hat kapiert, dass ich derjenige bin, der sie raus gelassen hat zuerst.
Und das fand sie super.
dass ich natürlich auch die Terrasse da soweit umgebaut habe
dass
ähm
dass sie da raus kann, das weiß sie natürlich nicht
aber die hat schon gecheckt
dass ich sie da jetzt zum ersten mal raus gelassen habe und das fand sie ganz
toll und
seitdem schleimt die auch viel mehr bei mir rum so
es könnte aber auch dran liegen, dass sie jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre länger da ist
keine Ahnung
das ist das Sonneneis
Also das hat, das hat Chico tatsächlich noch nie gemacht.
Chico beißt und kratzt mich nur, wenn sie sie überkommt, weil sie jetzt irgendwie ganz wilde Spielanfälle hat.
Aber dann beißt sie auch nicht richtig fest, sondern, ja, ein bisschen, also nur wenn sie es, wenn sie es überkommt.
Also der einzige Fehler, den man nicht machen darf, ist bei der, wenn sie anfängt ein bisschen zu beißen und kratzen, die Hand wegzuziehen, weil dann tust du dir weh.
Wenn du die Hand da lässt, dann passiert eigentlich gar nichts.
Da muss man sich aber auch erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Weiß man ja nicht. Ja, wenn man die Katze nicht kennt und die Katze fängt an, in die Hand zu beißen und du denkst dir,
okay, wenn die jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr beißt, dann tut's weh und dann blutet's, dann ziehst du vielleicht die Hand instinktiv weg,
aber dann ist Chico der Meinung, sie muss die Hand jetzt fangen. Wenn du die Hand einfach da lässt, ist eigentlich alles okay.
Und das ist dann auch das Einzige, was meine Katze mag, ist, wenn's ums Spielen geht, ist entweder so mit meiner Hand spielen
Anspielen oder das einzige was sie sonst noch mag ist so eine komische angel
Wo allerdings nichts mehr dran ist sondern nur noch der nur noch der faden dran hängt aber den faden finden wir auch furchtbar geil
Ja ja die brauchen manchmal ein bisschen für
Ja das ist normal
Dass sie am rück dass sie am bauch nicht gestreichelt werden wollen also das das habe ich auch jetzt dass das habe ich auch schon
gelernt also also auch bei den letzten schon oder schon schon früher wo ich
kleiner war nur weil die sich auf den rücken legen zum bauch streicheln
dann heißt nicht dass die bauch gestreichelt werden wollen das heißt
eher so eine geste wie ach guck mal wie wie schön entspannt ich bin und die
meisten mögen das nicht am bauch gestreichelt zu werden
das ist eher so ich bin ich bin super entspannt und was man auch nicht
vergessen darf ist dieses ich leg mich so seitlich hin ist bei katzen auch
oftmals Verteidigungshaltung, weil, ähm, also, es gibt ja so Leute, die sagen, oh, guck mal, die Katze unterwirft sich so, weil sie so auf dem Rücken liegt, stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das ist, das ist Verteidigung, also oftmals Verteidigungshaltung, was sie auch in freier Wildbahn machen, weil sie dann eben mit den Hinter-, mit den, mit den Krallen von den Hinterbeinen und mit den Krallen von den, von den Vorderpfoten sich verteidigen können.
Also auf den Rücken legen ist oftmals, je nachdem natürlich, was die Katze für Anzeige, ich mein, ist das auch Verteidigungshaltung.
Also, nur weil es nicht eine Katze ist, die auf den Rücken legt, ich würde um Leben nicht an den Bauch gehen.
Also, wenn du, ähm, wenn du gekratzt werden willst, dann, äh, geh an den Bauch, ja.
Wobei ich ja manchmal meine Katze ein bisschen ärgere.
Ich tu dann halt so, als will ich da an den Bauch gehen und dann, äh, kann man ein bisschen, kann sie mich versuchen zu fangen.
So, gut, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Okay, Chat, was wollen wir uns als erstes angucken? Wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit, also
wir gucken uns heute auf jeden Fall an
das Wichtigste, was bei der Apple-Konferenz rausgekommen ist.
Wollen wir uns vorher angucken,
warum Java ein riesiges Comeback macht?
Java
Oder auch java vielleicht
Am schlimmsten finde ich ja javascript wie er das immer ausspricht
Javascript
Okay, hat er gerade die suche reingekletscht
Ja.
Ok.
Javascript.
Java. Ich fand die Aussprache zu geil.
Also wahrscheinlich ist die sogar richtig.
Wie spricht, ich weiß gar nicht ob es überhaupt eine offizielle Aussprache von Java gibt.
Ich dachte eigentlich, ich dachte früher zumindest immer,
dass Java was mit dieser Insel zu tun hat.
Allerdings wurde ich eines besseren belehrt, dass Java gar nicht wirklich was mit der Insel
zu tun hat, sondern, dass das wohl tatsächlich von dem Kaffee kommt.
Ja, und wisst ihr, Quizfrage, ohne zu googeln Leute, und es gibt auch nichts zu gewinnen,
5-Head-Test. Wisst ihr, wie der Binary-Header ist von einem Java-Binary? Also der File-Type-Header
oder wie nennt sich das? ELF-Header oder sowas? In hex. Der Binary-Header von einem Java-Executable.
in hex
Ich habe ich habe gedacht wir haben hier irgendwelche krassen java kenner
Koffee fast es ist es ist kaffee babe
Kaffee kaffee babe oder wie auch immer das ausspricht
Ihr wart schon, ihr wart schon halbwegs nah dran, ja.
Oh, dürfen wir das jetzt überhaupt noch auf Twitch noch sagen?
Weil, weil neue Guidelines und so.
Ich hab gedacht, wir haben hier krasse Java-Hacker-Mens, die wissen das.
Okay, also, Java.
Es ist Juni 5, 2023 und du schaust den Code-Report.
Java ist mein Lieblings-Programmungs-Language.
Um Spaß zu haben.
Du schaust den Code-Report.
Java ist mein Lieblings-Programmungs-Language.
Um Spaß zu haben.
Python-Entwickler feiern es, weil sie so viel Boilerplate haben.
C-Entwickler lachen über absurde Namen,
wie AbstractFactoryManagerSingletonServiceManagerFactory
C++
sagen, das hat nicht nur Java das Problem, ich habe auch schon in .NET teilweise Klassennamen
gesehen, die sind nicht mehr feierlich. Wobei ich in .NET tatsächlich relativ selten sehe,
dass irgendwas Manager heißt. Factory, ja, ist sogar im .NET Framework öfters mal drinne.
Singleton selber sehe ich auch äußerst selten in Klassennamen drinne, aber sag mal so, in
Fällt mir eigentlich hauptsächlich das factory manchmal vorkommt aber der und service service service und und factory
Aber das ist tatsächlich gar nicht mal so weit weg user ach du hast recht tatsächlich ja da habe ich jetzt gar nicht
Daran gedacht du hast recht
Ja, ja, aber es ist aber es ist keine manager factory
Ja, du hast recht stimmt gibt es gibt es auch ist mir gerade nicht eingefallen, aber es ist nicht so weit weg von der realität
C++-Developers hate that you can't blow your legs off with memory management as easily,
and JavaScript developers are still trying to fix things like dates they copied from
Java over 20 years ago.
Unfortunately I have some bad news.
Public static void main string args will no longer be a requirement to write hello world
in C++.
Wait a minute, haben die sich das fancy sharp abgeguckt?
Können die jetzt auch sharp sehen, ja?
Insert den 0850 Paints Champ Java C-Sharp Witz
Weil das haben die in C-Sharp auch vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit eingeführt, dass man, wobei man in C-Sharp tatsächlich
das hier weglassen kann und direkt Console.WriteLine schreiben darf
Allerdings, und da muss ich mich jetzt mal outen
GachiBass
Ich mag das nicht
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber wir gucken das Video erstmal weiter.
Das ist eine tolle Veränderung, aber ich denke, dass wir die Dinge etwas besser machen können, indem wir auch Void entfernen.
Und warum brauchen wir eigentlich eine Hauptfunktion?
Wir könnten das alles lösen.
Und überzeugt die ganzen Python und Express, JS und sonst was Fanboys,
dass sie sich mal C Sharp angucken.
Weil das jetzt auch so kurz und knackig ist.
Aber, wenn man weiß, wie C Sharp das unter der Haube handelt,
finde ich es tatsächlich besser, man würde es einfach klar hinschreiben.
Weil dadurch dass man das so schreiben kann, suggeriert das ja irgendwie, dass C Sharp
quasi Code außerhalb von Funktionen kann, oder noch besser, Funktionen außerhalb von
Klassen kann.
Und das stimmt beides nicht.
Was ich übrigens auch persönlich nicht verstehe, warum in C Sharp nicht direkt Funktionen
außerhalb von Klassen erlaubt sind.
Auf der einen Seite, ja, ich weiß, mit Umwegen geht das natürlich, ja, du kannst irgendwelche Lambda-Ausdrücke, Variablen zuweisen, oder du kannst lokale Functions machen und sowas, aber warum kann ich in C-Sharp nicht einfach schreiben, int blub?
Und das ist dann eine Funktion, die nicht zu irgendeiner Klasse gehören muss.
Ja, oder man, man vielleicht, vielleicht hätten sie dafür irgendeinen, irgendwie einen Pfeil, irgendwas.
Oder irgendwas, was man direkt im Namespace auf, was auch immer.
Da gibt es sicherlich ein paar gute Sachen.
Das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht, warum man das in C Sharp nicht gemacht hat, schon längst.
Weil, sie versuchen die letzten Sprachen, die letzten Versionen über die Sprache immer funktionaler zu machen.
Also nicht Java, sondern C Sharp.
Und da würde das irgendwie einfach dazu passen.
Und es geht ja auch schon über ein paar kleine Umwege, warum nicht einfach Top-Level-Funktionen erlauben.
Das verstehe ich in C Sharp tatsächlich nicht so ganz, warum sie das gemacht haben.
Aber, nachdem das nicht der Fall ist, und ich denke, um jetzt mal zurückzukommen zu Java,
ich denke, dass sie das in Java ähnlich machen werden, wie in C Sharp, wegen Objektorientierung.
Ja gut, aber wie gesagt, sie versuchen die Sprache deutlich funktionaler zu machen, die letzten Versionen über und sie sind selbst auch, wenn man sich mal ihre ganzen Bilder und Interface-Geschichten ansieht, die sie eingeführt haben, die sind selber auch in der Standard-Library in .NET nicht mehr so richtig krass objektorientiert unterwegs wie früher.
So, und ich vermute mal, dass Java, wenn sie sowas einführen, das genauso machen wie C Sharp, nämlich, dass sie das einfach faken.
Und deswegen bin ich auch gar kein fan mehr davon mittlerweile wie gesagt ursprünglich dachte ich mir das eine super idee so was einzuführen
Das überzeugt die ganzen python fanboys sich mal eine ordentliche sprache anzugucken, keg wait
Aber unter der haube generiert das hier einfach nur für dich
automatisch eine
Static void main oder static int main args methode
Und eine klasse drumherum
Und das ist mir zu viel Magic unter der Haube.
Wenn es das doch eh braucht,
weil die Runtime oder was auch immer, der Compiler oder wie auch immer,
das sonst nicht übersetzen kann.
Warum?
Lass es die Leute doch einfach hinschreiben.
Dann weißt du wenigstens, was passiert.
Weil unterm Strich sorgt das einfach nur für Verwirrung.
Weil du denkst, du kannst einfach Code in eine CSS-Datei schreiben und es geht.
Es funktioniert aber gar nicht.
Es funktioniert nur bei der allerersten Datei, weil bei der nächsten Datei sagt er wahrscheinlich sowas wie Duplicate Declaration Static Main.
Oder nee, der sagt was anderes. Der sagt irgendwie Top Level Statements only irgendwie in einem Pfeil oder irgendwie sowas.
Deswegen muss ich sagen, ich fand es cool bei der Ankündigung, aber jetzt im Nachhinein muss ich sagen, es war keine so gute Idee.
Und einige Sachen, die sie in C-Sharp, die letzten Versionen, eingeführt haben, dachte ich mir eigentlich ganz cool, aber
der Konsistent halber und der Logik halber, hätte man es vielleicht lieber
sein lassen sollen.
Auch die ganze Geschichte, die sie jetzt einführen mit
Rekordstruct,
Classstruct,
Refstruct und
Jetzt demnächst Top Level Constructors und sowas oder ne wie heißt das, Class Level Constructors
Da blickt doch keine Sau mehr durch
Und du hast dann Sachen die sehen total ähnlich aus aber verhalten sich im Detail anders
Das hätte eigentlich alles nicht sein gemusst
Also Record Types ist okay gewesen
Aber die ganzen anderen Dinger drum herum
Ich weiß ja nicht
So aber jetzt, wir sind ja bei Java
Kekssoße fragt, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ich hab das nicht ganz verstanden, also muss ich jetzt in Zukunft nicht mehr die Static
Void Arcs Methode...
Ja!
Das hast du richtig verstanden.
Du kannst es jetzt abkürzen.
Allerdings, ich vermute, dass sie das genauso machen werden, wie in C Sharp, dass die unter
der Haube exakt das gleiche generieren, wie vorher nötig war, nur dass du es nicht mehr
schreiben musst.
Und das wird da auch für Inkonsistenzen sorgen, weil die Leute verwirrt sind, warum sie nur in einem File das benutzen dürfen.
Nutzt keiner? Also in der .NET-Welt ist das mittlerweile sogar im Standard-Application-Template so, dass das benutzt wird mit Top-Level-Statements.
Go ist nicht einfach.
Go versucht möglichst widerspruchsvoll zu sein.
Okay, einfach, wenn du das mit einfach meinst, gebe ich dir recht.
An sich muss ich sagen, ist Go nicht einfach, wenn es um die, wie soll ich sagen, die kurz
und knackige, elegante Umsetzung von manchen Sachen geht.
Beispiel, musstest du jahrelang nested Schleifen in Go schreiben, weil die halt gesagt haben,
nested Schleifen ist besser als irgendwie Arrayfilter.
Was ich mega bescheuert fand, aber gut, das war halt die Go-Philosophie, die haben gesagt,
okay, es soll alles möglichst schön klar sein, dass man immer sieht, was passiert und
immer nur möglichst einen Weg geben, wobei selbst das ja bei Go nicht so ganz stimmt,
ja.
Bei Go so Sachen wie deine Error-Objects, du hast aber trotzdem einen Panic und du hast
ein Recover von dem Panic.
Heißt das Recover in Go oder war das Rust?
Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Bring ich das durcheinander?
War das Rust?
Go, Panic, Recover.
Also sprich, das ist so ein Ding, was ich bei Go auch nicht so ganz kapiert habe.
Auf der einen Seite soll man Error-Handling machen über Return-Objekte, allerdings auf
der anderen Seite hat man Panic und Recover, was wiederum sowas ähnliches wie ein Try-Expect
ist.
Oder Try-Catch ist.
Aber insgesamt möchte Go relativ widerspruchsfrei sein und das kriegen sie eigentlich auch ganz
gut hin.
Ja, du hast zwar immer noch drei Varianten, wie du deine Variablen anlegen kannst, aber die haben tatsächlich sogar ihren Sinn.
Ja, du kannst ja in Go... Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich es aus dem Kopf hinkriege.
Du kannst ja in Go schreiben, var blub, var blub gleich 1...
Ne, Moment, Moment. Schwachsinn. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Go, äh, int... Oh Gott, ich krieg Go aus dem Kopf nicht hin.
Ähm...
Ich glaube das geht, dann kannst du irgendwie sagen
Int plupp
Und das geht auch
Ohne und dann kannst du so machen noch ja also
Ich kenne die guidelines zumindest immer wenn ich was in go mache kenne ich sie kurzzeitig
Wann man was verwendet
Aber das auch nicht so ganz klar aber go go versucht tatsächlich relativ widerspruchsfrei zu sein das ist glaube ich auch das was man der sprache
Vom style her mit am ehesten noch anrechnen kann ich persönlich mag go von der sündagshelig
Ich habe auch schon wir haben sogar im stream schon sachen in so in go programmiert es ist nicht so dass man nicht
Go mich nicht gut programmieren könnte also go ist durchaus in ordnung
Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Standard-Library teilweise ein bisschen, auch wenn das eines der Punkte ist, die immer übelst hoch gelobt wird von Go, Go hat coole Sachen in der Standard-Library, aber manche Sachen fehlen einfach.
Zum Beispiel wie ordentliches Date-Time-Handling.
Die haben viele Sachen drinnen, die man braucht, aber so essentielle Sachen wie zum Beispiel einen ordentlichen Timestamp-Typ haben sie nicht.
Ich weiß, es gibt Time Delta, aber mit Time Delta kannst du nicht gescheit rechnen.
Also, wo ich mir jetzt immer so denke, ja, cool, gibt es, aber nee, das, was ich machen will, geht so ohne weiteres nicht.
Da muss ich selbst irgendwas basteln.
Das hat mich teilweise manchmal ein bisschen an C++ erinnert.
Aber insgesamt ist Go tatsächlich ganz angenehm.
Aber trotzdem muss ich sagen, ich persönlich mag die Go-Syntax nicht.
Was ich auch ein bisschen nervig finde bei Go...
Was ich aber auch verstehen kann, dass es irgendwie Sinn macht, aber ich mag es nicht, ist diese erzwungene
Typeche- äh diese erzwungene Syntax-Checking-Geschichte.
Ja, dass du nicht kompilieren kannst, wenn was auskommentiert ist.
Dass das nicht kompiliert, wenn du die If-Else-Klammern
falsch gesetzt hast oder falsch gesetzt hast in Go-Logik.
Also, das ist was was mich bei, dass du Imports nicht einfach mal drin stehen lassen kannst, wenn du mal kurz halt was auskommentieren musst und sowas.
Also, einiges an Go nervt, vieles fangen IDEs ab, weil die mitdenken, aber es gibt schon ein paar Sachen die nerven.
Ich kann bei den meisten Sachen nachvollziehen, warum man sich dafür entschieden hat, aber trotzdem ist Go nicht so richtig mein Fall.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht, dass es einen Error gibt, wenn man das nicht macht.
Du kannst sicherlich immer noch Static Void mal hinschreiben, allein schon die 100 Jahre
Java Legacy Code.
Da haben sie aber viel zu tun, zu C++ aufzuschließen.
Also ich glaube, im Thema Bullshit schließt keiner jemals wieder zu C++ auf.
Ich glaube, die einzigen, die die Bullshitterei von C++ noch übertreffen können, sind irgendwelche so esoterischen Programmiersprachen, die explizit erschaffen wurden, um kacke zu sein.
C++ ist die einzige Programmiersprache, die es schafft, scheiße zu sein, obwohl man eigentlich nicht scheiße sein als Ziel hat.
Das schaffen sonst nur so Sprachen wie Brainfuck oder Whitespace oder sowas.
Nein, selbst PHP ist nicht kacke.
PHP ist mittlerweile sogar ganz okay.
Gerade mit irgendeinem halbwegs gescheiten Framework.
Aber C++ ist die einzige ernst gemeinte Programmiersprache,
die es schafft, sich über die letzten Jahre noch wirrer und noch widersprüchlicher immer wieder zu gestalten.
Ja, also Werbung für hasserfüllten C++-Content darf ich nicht machen.
C++ ist auch gut, wenn man keinen Legacy-Code hat.
Hast du dir mal angeguckt, die Hilfe-Seite von EnableCons-Moment, pass mal auf, wo wir
dabei sind, C++.
Wo, so.
Okay.
Und jetzt erzähl mir nochmal, dass modernes C++ gut ist.
Ich gebe zu, das ist ein bisschen fieses Beispiel, weil Templates aber schon mal abfuck an sich
sind.
Templates sind quasi eines der geilsten und beschissensten Features von C++ zugleich.
Ja, also allein schon, dass sowas in der Standard-Library drin ist und du brauchst, weißt du schon
mal, es ist komplett lost.
Standard is trivially destructible.
Da weißt du echt Bescheid, oder?
Da weißt du, die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht und vor allem das hier, Alter, das verstehe
ich.
Na gut.
Jetzt mal wie gesagt also C++ Templates sind eines der geilsten und beschissensten Features in einem
Was was dieses Beispiel, weil wie gesagt
Eigentlich ist es ein bisschen ein unfaires Beispiel sich jetzt ausgerechnet so ein komisches Ding da raus zu picken um zu sagen wie kacke C++ ist
Aber das ist sinnbildlich für C++ und wie sich das die letzten Jahre über entwickelt
Aber um das jetzt noch mal zu unterstreichen
Wie bescheuert das eigentlich ist wir sind hier in quasi in der C++ Reference
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das die offiziellen Docs sind oder nicht, aber ich glaube, das ist somit das offiziellste an Docs, was es gibt für C++.
Also, man muss sich mal überlegen.
Irgendjemand hat Doku geschrieben für dieses Feature, was wir hier sehen.
Und hat sich gedacht, das hier ist das beste Beispiel, was ihm einfällt, in der besten Formatierung.
Also sprich, das ist das Beste, was man machen kann in C++, um dieses Feature zu demonstrieren.
Das sollte, glaube ich, alles über die Syntaxerweiterung und Sache dieser Sprache aussehen.
Also irgendjemand dachte, das ist das beste Beispiel, was wir präsentieren können für
dieses Feature.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es das auch.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal gelogen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das beste Beispiel für dieses Feature.
Aber es ist halt komplett unreadable.
Sister Insight.
Sogar jemand, der keine Ahnung davon hat, erkennt...
Gut, ich kann nicht sagen...
Ich mein, what the hell?
Was bitteschön ist das hier schonmal?
Das ist das... oder?
Es kann das sein?
Okay, okay. Alter!
What the fuck?
Okay, es ist enabled if...
Wenn es nicht...
Wenn es nicht trivially destructible of T ist, also irgendein generic type, und wenn es eine Klasse ist, warum auch immer das hier jetzt an der Stelle geschweifte Klammern, geschweifte Klammern auf und zu haben muss, an der Stelle, ich dachte es ist eine Typdefinition, was auch immer, es ist C++, muss man nicht hinterfragen, oder das, what the fuck, ja das hatten wir schon mal, das musste jetzt sein, weil jemand gesagt hat,
C++, modernes C++ ist geil.
Da muss ich gleich mal sagen, nein, modernes C++ ist nicht zwangsläufig geil.
Man kann sicherlich auch schön programmieren in C++, das will ich gar nicht bestreiten,
aber das Cremium, das C++-Standard-Konsortium, Cremium, wie auch immer die heißen, sind nicht
sonderlich bemüht die sprache besser lesbar und konsistent dazu machen die
letzten versionen über die führen lieber 500 neue sonderzeichen ein ans
trinken erinnern ok ok ist gut leute
ich habe getrunken
Ja, dann wird das nicht funktionieren, aber auch an Main brauchst du Annotations, Tomox
danke für den Sub.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sehe es ja auch so, ich verstehe oftmals warum die das in Go gemacht
haben.
Deswegen ist es regt aber auch mit vorbei, dass ich Go jetzt nicht so angenehm empfinde.
Max kann doch auch Python in Go einbetten oder man kann aber nicht Max, ja Max könnte das vielleicht auch, man kann doch auch Python in Go einbetten.
Also ich will jetzt nicht ausschließen, dass irgendwelche verrückten Leute auf GitHub sowas gebaut haben,
dass du quasi Go in Python templaten kannst, was dann wäre dem Compile-Vorgang
On-The-Fly Go generiert und bestimmt, bestimmt
Aber so bekannt wäre mir das jetzt erst mal nicht. Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst
Auf jeden fall aus Python heraus Go-Sachen aufrufen, allerdings auch nur wenn du die als
C-Funktion exportiert hast vorher. Und C-Go ist auch so ein Ding, was nicht viel Liebe bekommt von den von den Go-Entwicklern.
Umgedreht, dass du Python aus Go heraus aufrufst,
wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wie man das gescheit machen soll, weil zumindest die Standard-Go-Sachen sind ja keine
Binarys mit mit irgendwelchen
C-kompatiblen Interface, also C-kompatiblen Funktionsdefinitionen, die man callen kann,
sondern irgendwas, was erstmal da gejettet werden muss von irgendeiner Python-Runtime.
Wenn du das Python-Zeug vielleicht im Vorfeld kompilierst mit irgendeinem der Python-Compiler
und dann irgendwelche C-Interfaces da exportieren kannst, dann mag es vielleicht funktionieren.
Aber das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, tatsächlich, das irgendwie miteinander zu verheiraten.
Ja, aber trotzdem gefällt mir die Syntax nicht.
Warum kopierst du eigentlich immer einzelne Buchstaben in die Zwischenablage?
Meinst du sowas hier?
Weiß ich nicht, weil ich mir das so ange- Also eigentlich mache ich es ja hauptsächlich
so.
Das ist so eine Angewohnheit von mir.
Wenn du es genau wissen willst, musst du Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat eingeben, da gibt es eine Erklärung
für.
Das ist doch CheapAid, damit fangen wir jetzt nicht an, ich habe mich lange genug darüber
ausgelassen, sonst rante ich jetzt die nächsten 15 Minuten über C++.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich hab mich die letzten Jahre tatsächlich mit relativ vielen Sprachen beschäftigt.
Wir haben uns ja auch hier im Stream... Ich glaube, Chat, ich glaube, dass eines der wenigen Sachen, die wir noch nicht im Stream gemacht haben, ist Ruby on Rails, kann das sein?
Wobei ich früher... Ich kriege es, glaube ich, nicht mehr gebacken gescheit.
Aber ich hab früher sehr viel in Ruby gemacht, also wirklich viel. Immer alles, was es zu Skripten gab, hab ich in Ruby gemacht.
Und ich hab auch die ein oder andere Rails-Geschichte gemacht.
gemacht ich weiß nicht ob euch das interessiert ob wir irgendwann mal was
kleines in ruby on rails machen sollen ich glaube ich habe ich glaube schon
wieder fast alles vergessen ruby
ja php
ich ja leute das ist tatsächlich was gutes das müssen wir mal machen
stream themen ich wollte mir seit ewigkeiten schon mal wieder leroy mit
PAP angucken. Ich habe mit Laravel mal was gemacht vor Jahren. Also hat irgendjemand
zufällig damals auf meinem Battlefield 4 Server gespielt und die Server-Signatur verwendet?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich hatte damals für meinen Battlefield 4 Server eine Statistik-Signatur
gebaut, die man sich generieren konnte. So mit dieser Server, so viel Kills und sowas
in der Richtung. So viel Kills, so eine KD und sowas. Ich habe quasi so ein Mini-Battle-Log
gebaut nur für meinen Server. Damals im Battlefield 4. Und das habe ich in PAP und Laravel gemacht.
Der Grund war, der Grund war relativ einfach. Es gab irgendwie super billiges Webhosting
mit MySQL und PHP und der Battlefield Surfer brauchte selbst für Statistiken zu locken
schon die MySQL Datenbank und die war schon bei dem Anbieter und deswegen hat sich das
einfach angeboten.
C-Sharp ist Poggers.
Hatte heute auch jemand die mündliche Abschlussprüfung?
Das gebe ich mal weiter, Chat.
Also ich nicht.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt das Video weiter.
Ich meine, wir haben es ernsthaft geschafft, in einer halben Stunde, glaube ich, eine Minute
Video zu gucken.
Das musst du erstmal hinkriegen.
Okay, wir sind verstehen geblieben, ich spule mal kurz ein paar Sekunden zurück.
Public Static Void Main String Args.
This is a great change, but I think we could actually make things a little bit better by
also removing Void.
And actually, why do we even need a main function in the first place?
We could get rid of that altogether.
System out seems a little unnecessary.
There should just be a global print line function.
And if we rename it to print, we then get a perfect language.
C sharp introduced top.
Da kann man sich jetzt, tatsächlich, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, da kann man
sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich weiß, der Python-Way und sowas in der Richtung, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das ohne Namespaces und alles wirklich so das Geilste ist.
Und wenn wir es zu Print nennen, bekommen wir dann eine perfekte Sprache.
C Sharp hat 2020 Top-Level-Statemente vorgestellt, und vielleicht wird es in 10 Jahren auch in
Java sein.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich finde im Nachhinein betrachtet C Sharp auch keine gute Entscheidung.
Bevor Sie zu sehr aufgeregt sind, ist diese Feature vor allem, um Java für Anfänger
Was bin ich sehend, irgendwas, irgendwelche Java Generics?
Future T? Ist Future T sowas wie Task in C-Sharp?
Wahrscheinlich. Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Chat, warum haben die zwei Return Types?
Warum haben die einen T als Return Type und eine List auf Future T?
Da hört mein Java-Verständnis jetzt schon auf, warum die zwei Return Types.
Warum die zwei Return Types haben.
Irgendwelche Java-Magic, keine Ahnung.
Das ist Java-Exception-Zeug, dass man das angeben muss, was das werfen kann, okay, das, und
Der Rest ist erstaunlich schwierig zu lesen, für das, dass sie das irgendwie erst jetzt letztens designt haben.
Ja, okay.
crazy about java is that it doesn't natively support string interpolation which means you
need to concatenate a bunch of strings together like you're in kindergarten or use string.format
which is also kind of annoying but in java 21 we have a new string templates feature which
is a new kind of expression that allows you to insert values directly
man muss da nicht wirklich str. da vorschreiben oder das ist ja die hässlichste sündags
die ich, glaube ich, in allen Sprachen je gesehen habe, was String Interpolation angeht.
Und...
Und warum muss ich... warum muss ich ein Backslash machen vor...
vor dem... vor dem eigentlichen Escape?
Das ist ja...
Äh!
Das sieht doch nicht wirklich so aus, oder?
Also, Stringformat geht doch voll klar, weißt du, was das bisschen blöde an Stringformat
ist?
Dass es einfach so doppelt und dreifach ist, ich meine, du musst hier den Text eingeben
mit den Lücken, du brauchst hier quasi Platzhalter und dann hinten musst du die in der richtigen
Reihenfolge einsetzen.
Warum kannst du die nicht einfach hier einsetzen, an der Stelle, wo du es haben willst?
Also ich finde ordentliche String Interpolation viel, viel besser als so ein Format Ding.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz angucken. Java 21 String Templates. Da brauchen wir ein Beispiel von.
String Templates Preview. Da gibt es da vielleicht auch mal ein kurzes
Beispiel. Ja. Harness the Power of String Templates.
Okay, ja, so macht man es nicht.
Das ist JavaScript-Syntax?
Haben die das jetzt übernommen aus JavaScript?
Das ist original die JavaScript-Template-Syntax.
Und ich habe sogar bemerkt, dass Java ihre Webseite recently update hat, sodass sie jetzt
aus aber aber wächst nicht mal mit 2005 oder
Ja, ich auch. Also wenn ich... Das wollte ich mir übrigens auch mal mit euch irgendwann zusammen angucken, Kotlin.
Wenn ich jemals was für die Java Runtime baue, dann auf jeden Fall nicht in Java selbst.
Und Scala benutze ich auch nicht, weil es hat mir zu viele Klammern.
Es ist ausreichend performant für die meisten Dinge, es ist relativ einfach zu benutzen und
vor allem hat es ein riesiges Ökosystem von stabilen Bibliotheken und Frameworken.
Ein paar Tage zuvor habe ich eine Polstunde für die beste Programmierungssprache aller Zeiten gemacht.
Die wollen mir nicht einfach erzählen, dass C++, das ist doch Dschibait, oder?
Und Javascript ist sicherlich auch nicht die beste Sprache aller Zeiten.
Aber Javascript hat sich gemacht die letzten Jahre über.
Im Gegensatz zu C++.
Also man könnte sagen...
Javascript hat die umgekehrte Entwicklung von C++ gemacht.
Die Javascript-Standard-Leute, die haben die letzten 15 Jahre über aus einer ziemlich ekeligen Sprache eine echt ganz gut
benutzbare und
auch durchdachte Sprache gemacht mit den neuen Features.
Und auch den Standard-Library-Erweiterungen und sowas schon ganz okay. Also sie haben ihre Sprache eindeutig deutlich verbessert die letzten
letzten 15 jahre über c++ hat auch einige punkte verbessert so ist es nicht aber ganz ganz viel scheiße drauf gepackt
Also insofern
Also hier in dieser abstimmung würde ich sagen wenn es um sprachen geht in denen ich gerne programmieren würde ich sagen tatsächlich java script auf
platz 1
python auf platz 2
Ja und c++ und java ist mir egal
Args, I think it'll reclaim the top spot.
And with that being said, I'd like to officially announce my retirement from making fun of
Java.
But let's enjoy these Java memes together one last time.
Like this one, that explains how object-oriented design patterns are often unnecessary and
counterproductive, when you could just be using simple variables and functions.
This next meme is a good one, but you wouldn't get it, so I'm not even going to try to
explain it.
If you like Windows, you might like Java, because it loves to force you into annoying
updates all the time.
And as you gain more experience as a programmer, you'll eventually find out that everything
doesn't need to be an object, because these objects will pile up and devour your RAM.
And finally, it's important to realize that not every meme is a joke, many of them are
a legitimate cry for help.
This has been the Code Report, thanks for watching, and I will see you in the next one.
was lustiges von der Arbeit erzählen, dann habe ich das nie, nie, nie erzählt.
Okay, dann erzähle ich es euch jetzt schnell.
Also, hatten wir schon, nein, hatten wir noch nicht.
Also, heute hatten wir eine lustige, lustige Diskussion.
Nein, das hat nichts mit C++, das hat was mit Cloud-Geschichten zu tun.
Heute haben wir eine lustige Diskussion.
Und zwar, vielleicht kennt ihr es von anderen oder vielleicht kennt ihr es auch von eurem Arbeitgeber.
Arbeitgeber, wenn neue Systeme gebaut werden oder Services, nennen wir mal Services, wenn
neue Services gebaut werden, da wird das ja nicht meistens nur einmal hingestellt und
läuft dann da produktiv drauf und das war's.
Also die meisten haben zumindest mal irgendwie sowas wie eine Testumgebung oder irgendein
Test-Environment, um zu gucken, ob irgendwelche neuen Versionen was kaputt machen.
Also sagen wir mal, ein Test-Environment und ein Live-Environment, das haben wahrscheinlich
die meisten, die ernsthaft irgendwelche Services betreiben.
In der Regel haben die meisten sogar noch ein Entwicklungs-Environment, ein Test-Environment
und ein Live-Environment.
Manche haben auch noch mehr, ist aber auch jetzt egal.
Also ich denke, dass man so ein Staging hat, quasi in Form von Entwicklungs-Umgebung,
dann sowas wie Test-Abnahme-Umgebung, dann Live-Produktions-Umgebung.
Mein Beileid.
Egal, ihr macht einfach keine Fehler. Und wenn man keine Fehler macht, dann kann man auch immer alles direkt in Brot hauen. Das ist auch easy. Spart vor allem Geld.
So, also ich glaube, das können sich einige durchaus vorstellen, dass es sinnvoll ist, so drei Umgebungen zu haben.
So, und jetzt für ein neues Projekt hatten wir heute eine Diskussion. Also es gibt aktuell eine Entwicklungsumgebung und eine Testumgebung.
Und dann später soll es eine Live-Umgebung geben.
So, und heute hat man sich überlegt, okay, man braucht ja quasi eine Testumgebung, man
braucht eine Entwicklungsumgebung und man braucht noch so eine wir-wollen-neue-Versionen-testen-Umgebung.
So, und jetzt sind sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, ey, warum sollen wir eigentlich
drei kubernetes cluster hinstellen bei google wenn man doch auch alles in
unterschiedlichen namespaces machen kann in ein kubernetes cluster und da wollte
ich mal zu bedenken geben also das heißt aber auch wenn ein cluster weg ist ist
alles weg also das heißt es kann niemand mehr testen es kann niemand mehr
gescheit entwickeln es kann keiner mehr neue version weil der cluster ist ja
weg ja so und das argument dafür warum man keine eigenen cluster für die
unterschiedliche Umgebung haben wollte, sondern das alles einfach nur über Namespaces trennen will in Kubernetes war. Und jetzt haltet euch fest, ratet mal,
ratet mal, was könnte das sein? Ich meine, ihr wisst es wahrscheinlich eh schon.
Spart, spart Geld.
Spart Geld
und
spart Geld, auch wenn es nicht so richtig ernst gemeint war, habe ich den Eindruck gehabt, aber spart Geld und
daraufhin habe ich mal gefragt, aber sagt mal
So, unser Entwicklungs-Kubernetes-Cluster, ja, der kostet 120 Euro im Monat, das ist die allerkleinste Ausführung.
Ich meine, wir sind eine Bank mit Milliarden. Jucken wir uns 120 Euro für ein Kubernetes-Cluster im Monat? Wirklich?
Da mussten auch alle mal eine Runde kacken.
Und ich hoffe, dass sie das jetzt wieder verworfen haben und machen einfach für jede Umgebung einen Cluster-Mann.
Vielleicht ist das zu billig, vielleicht müsste das mindestens 5.000 Euro kosten.
Ja, dann denkt man, okay, das ist es wert. Ja, weiß nicht.
Ich meine ernsthaft, allein schon die Diskussion sollen wir 120...
Ach ja, und dann kam gleich der Nächste um die Ecke und meinte, ja, dann können wir doch auch einfach nur noch eine Cloud SQL Datenbank hinstellen und dort verschiedene Datenbanken drin anlegen.
Und ich so, Alter, das kostet, keine Ahnung, das kostet 25 Euro im Monat oder so.
Das Storage ist ja das Teure, unterm Strich.
Jetzt stellt euch mal nicht so an, Mann.
150 Euro im Monat für eine Testdatenbank und ein Testkubernetescluster, Mensch.
Das wird doch so ein Milliarden-Unternehmen irgendwie locker haben, oder?
Und ich habe dann als Beispiel gebracht, also ich handhabe das ja immer so,
wenn wir über Zahlen reden, die ich normalerweise für mich privat, ohne mir es lange zu überlegen, bezahlen würde für ein Projekt,
dann kann es eigentlich für eine Versicherung nicht so weit her sein.
Aber da mussten sie mir tatsächlich sogar irgendwie recht geben.
Ich bin jetzt nicht scharf drauf, 120 Euro im Monat für ein kubanenes Cluster privat auszugeben,
aber wenn ich irgendwas hätte, was ich laufen lassen will,
also ich würde es ausgeben und ich würde es ausgeben können,
das sollte doch schon genug Indiz dafür sein,
dass man das als Milliardenversicherung auch ausgeben kann.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, aber das hat sich insoweit erledigt. Ich glaube, wir machen schlicht und ergreifend
Cluster, ein Cluster für jede Umgebung
Also ganz im Ernst, dass da überhaupt drüber diskutiert wurde, fand ich lustig irgendwie. Ich meine, the fuck, die machen
Millionen und Milliarden, die machen Geld ohne Ende, aber dann überlegen sie sich, ob 120 Euro Kubanenes Cluster irgendwie Probleme macht.
Wer stellt das in Frage?
Gar nicht nur einer, das war so eine allgemeine Frage.
Ein paar Leute waren der Meinung, ja, kann man, sollte man so machen.
Und ich hab halt die Ansicht vertreten, lasst uns das nicht machen mit Namespaces.
Einfach jede Umgebung, jedes Environment oder jedes Environment, was wir brauchen,
bekommt ein eigenes Environment.
Was besteht aus eigenem Google-Projekt, eigenem Cluster, eigener Test-Datenbank, was auch
immer.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wären das jetzt mega viele Sachen.
Du brauchst eine Testing-Umgebung, du brauchst irgendeine Entwicklungsumgebung und du brauchst
irgendwie dann live umgeben und wenn man dann noch und wenn man dann vielleicht noch mal für andere zwecke
Noch zwei drei andere braucht die zum größten teil auch nur temporär sind ist das kein problem
Ich war ganz im ernst selbst wenn alle umgebung mal die produktion ausgenommen zusammen
8000 euro im monat kosten würden selbst danach sollte realistisch betrachtet nicht kein hahn krähen
Die machen Millionen! Also jetzt mal ernsthaft!
C++-Devs when they see words instead of...
Ja ne, das geht natürlich nicht.
Die haben eindeutig Spitzeklammer auf und zu vergessen.
Kein echter C++-Programmer.
Ja, also das wollte ich heute nur mal zum Besten geben.
Da seht ihr mal, was auch im Business Enterprise Umfeld so diskutiert wird, wo man sich echt
fragt so, macht das jetzt wirklich fett 120 Euro oder nicht?
Das bringt dir nicht so wirklich was in dem Fall.
Du hast schon recht also gerade gerade was so wir müssen was schnell was testen ja da ist minicube oder so ist natürlich toll aber
Ein lokaler komponentes cluster bringt dir höchstens was wenn du wenn du
Container starten stoppen und testen willst was da drin läuft wenn du das gesamte
System drumherum testen willst bringt es dir nix weil du brauchst
Also willst ja nicht nur deine software alleine testen du willst ja auch testen klappt ein terraform aufbau
klappt das automatische rolling update und solche geschichten und das nachdem
alles ziemlich eng verzahnt ist mit den services die google cloud bereitstellt
macht es eigentlich keinen sinn in lokalen kubernetes cluster für solche
tests aufzubauen sondern es sollte schon ein google kubernetes cluster ein gki
cluster sein was ja auch nicht schlimm ist ich meine es kostet 120 euro im
Monat. Irgendwann muss man sich nicht so anstellen.
Ich habe in der Arbeit gerade das Vergnügen, mich mit den BSI-Anforderungen für Kubernetes
auszuhalten. Der Vorschlag, alles in einem Cluster zu betreiben, würden gefühlt gegen
die Hälfte davon verstoßen. Ich würde prinzipiell auch nicht alles in einem Cluster betreiben.
Allein schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt, wenn Cluster mal nicht da ist, ist alles weg.
Und ich meine, es verkraftet auch nicht jede Anwendung gleich gut einen Rolling Update.
Musst du dir schon ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen. Also es ist eigentlich nicht sinnvoll.
Ja, und was man nicht vergessen darf, man darf ja auch nicht vergessen,
dass es Anwenderfehler geben kann oder Adminfehler.
Das ist auch ein Beispiel, weil ich bei sowas immer mal ganz gerne bringe, es wird nämlich
immer nur so getan, dass der einzige Grund, dass was kaputt gehen kann ist, dass Hardware
kaputt geht, Google scheiße baut oder Software kaputt ist, ne ne.
Es kann auch ganz normale Admin-Fehler geben.
Also man kann auch aus Persönlichkeit mal irgendwie Kacke bauen und wenn man das halt
gegen irgendeine Testing- und Entwicklungsumgebung macht, ist das nicht schlimm, aber wenn man
alles auf einem Cluster laufen hat, ist es vielleicht halt doch schlimm, weil da läuft
halt auch mal was Wichtiges nicht.
Also zumindest, zumindest einen Live Cluster und einen Bastel Cluster sollte man haben,
das sollte jeder haben.
Auf dem Bastel Cluster kann man meinetwegen, wenn man unbedingt so scharf drauf ist, in
unterschiedliche Namespaces, Entwicklungen und Testing Sachen laufen lassen, wobei ich
auch das nicht sagen würde.
Eigentlich Sollte Entwicklung in Einen Cluster Kriegen Testing in Einen Cluster Kriegen und die live umgebung in Einen Cluster Kriegen
Weil man wie gesagt man darf admin fehler auch nicht unterschätzen man baut auch mal scheiße man verklickt sich auch mal im webinterface
Man gibt auch Mal IrGendwo Mist ein Ja man man copy pasted auch mal das falsche rein das kann schon Mal passieren dass man Da Mist baut
Was gar nicht da der admin muss da gar nicht unfähig sein es passiert immer mal irgendein Mist also aus dem gesichtspunkt ist das sinnvoll
Nee, das finde ich nicht so schlimm.
Ich finde es gut, ganz ehrlich, ich finde es gut, dass sowas vorgeschlagen wird.
Ich finde es immer gut, wenn die Leute bei solchen Meetings frei sagen können, was sie
für Ideen haben.
Man muss die ja am Ende nicht machen.
Wenn man dann darauf, weil ansonsten traut sich keiner mehr was zu sagen.
Wenn einer mal ein bisschen was blödes sagt, und man regt sich dann gleich drüber auf, so nach dem Motto, er soll doch lieber die Klappe halten,
dann sagt er das nächste Mal nichts mehr. Und da wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll gewesen.
Also ich finde es immer gut, wenn in solchen Runden jeder einfach sagen kann, was ihm so in den Kopf kommt, an Ideen und Vorschlägen.
Man muss es ja nicht machen am Ende.
Und ich hoffe auch nicht, dass wir es machen.
Ja, das ist ein weiterer Punkt warum ich das, da hast du recht, das ist ein weiterer Punkt
warum ich die Dev-Umgebung nicht lokal mit Minikube oder besser gesagt mit Minikube ähnlich
mit irgendeinem lokalen Kubernetes-Täusch bauen würde und das andere in der Google Cloud
laufen.
Natürlich, möglichst gleich, man muss es nicht übertreiben, ja, also wenn man irgendwie
einen 16-Node-Cluster in Produktion hat, macht es ja überhaupt kein Problem nur einen 3-Node-Cluster
in Entwicklung zu benutzen.
Aber das ist ja das Schöne an der ganzen Kubernetes und Container Geschichte, dass das nochmal so eine Zwischenabstraktionsebene ist, dass du dich eigentlich darauf verlassen kannst, dass alles was da drinnen läuft, für die Anwendung da drin, dass dann kein großer Unterschied mehr ist.
Ja, DNS-Namen sind abstrahiert, Container von der Sache unten drunter abstrahiert, also das ist dann ganz gut.
Da kannst du auch ein Cluster unterschiedlich aufbauen, dann ist das für die Anwendung da drin eigentlich fast egal, ob das ein 16-Node-Cluster oder ein 3-Node-Cluster ist.
Gleiches Badget-Time, ja.
Ja klar, natürlich, kannst ja so sagen, du findest das eine blöde Idee, das ist schon...
Aber ich würde den nicht gleich sagen, so nach dem Motto, du hast dich selber disqualifiziert und so, dann haben die Leute das nächste Mal keinen Bock was zu sagen.
Und das ist tatsächlich was, was ich bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber wirklich gut finde und auch mit den Leuten, also auch bei mir im Team, womit ich jetzt schon zusammengearbeitet habe, aber gerade übergreifend im Projekt, da funktioniert das tatsächlich ganz gut.
Also, da ist keiner da, bisher zumindest noch nicht, keiner der sich bisher auf den Schlips getreten gefühlt hat, wenn man was gesagt hat, aber umgedreht geben die Leute sich auch Mühe, wenn sie der Meinung sind, dass man selbst Mist erzählt, das so zu verpacken, dass das nicht so negativ ankommt.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, also die geben sich alle Mühe, dass man gut miteinander zusammenarbeiten kann, was ich, was ich wirklich als sehr
angenehmen Vorteil empfinde versus mein, versus meinem, bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber. Da waren ein paar Leute dabei,
die sind, die, die, die, die haben quasi in den Meetings nur darauf gewartet, um an der passenden Stelle was zu sagen,
um irgendjemanden zu ärgern. Und das ist halt bescheuert, ne?
Wo, wo ich mir immer gedacht habe, hättest du denen das vorher gefragt,
dann hättest du das jetzt nicht absehbar, also, ey, muss ich anders sagen, also, mal angenommen,
also wir hatten beim alten Arbeitgeber, hatten wir Leute, die haben quasi gewartet,
bis irgendein Status-Meeting ist.
Und sie wussten im Vorfeld schon, dass irgendwas nicht so dolle ist.
Und anstatt, dass die im Vorfeld mal gefragt hätten,
so nach dem Motto, warum habt ihr das so gemacht, oder was ist,
irgendwie was mal gefragt, haben die dann in dem Meeting drauf gewartet,
um zu sagen, ah ich sehe, Punkt XY wurde immer noch nicht erledigt, so.
Ja, und das hat mich immer wahnsinnig aufgeregt, das,
wie, was für Kackspasten wir da hatten, ey, da waren teilweise so
nervige Leute am Start, das hat mich so abgefuckt.
Also beim alten Arbeitgeber, da waren so richtig nervige Leute dabei,
wo ich mir gedacht habe, die haben doch nur drauf gewartet,
in dem Meeting, dass sie jetzt an der Stelle was sagen konnten,
Wovon sie wussten, die wussten im Vorfeld, dass es Kacke ist und die haben sich das explizit aufgehoben für das Meeting, um das anzusprechen, dass es Kacke ist.
Office-Politics, ja klar, ist es.
Ne, das, das gar nicht mal so sehr, das, das hätte mich ja gar nicht gestört, das sind ja so organisatorische Sachen.
Ja, also, machen wir mal, machen wir mal irgendein, irgendwann ein bisschen konstruiertes Beispiel, ja.
Also mal angenommen, man braucht irgendwie Zertifikate für irgendeine neue Domain und man hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen zwei Wochen Verzug, für die man nichts kann, weil, keine Ahnung, die Abteilung, die das damit machen muss, irgendwie zu lahm ist.
Also mal angenommen, man braucht Zertifikate für eine Domain und irgendwie hat man Verzögerung und kann nix dafür, so.
Der andere weiß das und er weiß auch eigentlich, woran es liegt.
Nämlich, dass die andere Abteilung zu lahm ist, so.
Anstatt dass der im Vorfeld fragt, so nach dem Motto, sag mal hier, ich hab gesehen die Zertifikate sind immer noch nicht da.
Ähm, ist das immer noch so, dass das an den anderen hängt?
Ja, das wäre okay gewesen.
Ne, die Leute, so das ist jetzt ein Beispiel, wie das bei manchen Leuten bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber gelaufen ist.
Die Leute haben dann gewartet, bis das, bis das Weekly-Status-Meeting dazu ist,
haben absichtlich vergessen wieder, dass sie eigentlich wissen,
dass es nicht an denen liegt, die das Zertifikat beantragt haben, sondern an denen, die das Zertifikat ausstellen,
die vergessen oder die erwähnen das in diesem Meeting nicht und sagen dann auf dem Meeting sowas wie
ich sehe, Gruppe XY ist immer noch mit den Zertifikaten im Verzug, unter diesen Bedingungen können wir selbstverständlich unsere Software nicht zeitgemäß deployen.
Genau in dem Ton und genau in dieser Wortwahl und Variante, so in der Richtung wurde das
da gesagt.
Und genau, also Leute, die Betonung, die Aussprache und alles, das diente nur dazu, einfach nur
richtig krass die Leute abzufacken.
Das war der einzige Sinn dahinter.
Meistens konntest du das ja, meistens konntest du das natürlich ganz gut kontern, wenn du
ihm dann erzählst, ich hab dir doch letzte Woche das sogar noch gezeigt.
Ja, wenn du dann sagst, guck mal, wir haben doch letzte Woche sogar uns noch das Ticket
zusammen angeguckt.
Du weißt doch, was Sache ist, ja?
Erzähl ich so'n Zeug.
Das geht, aber dass du das überhaupt machen musstest, ist halt für'n Arsch, ja?
Oder was noch geiler ist, mein Lieblingsbeispiel, bestes Beispiel vom alten Arbeitgeber war,
das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt, oder?
Der Change Manager, der keine Changes managen wollte.
Das weiß ich noch.
Ich glaube, das habe ich euch schon erzählt.
Nur so ganz grob, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich es überhaupt richtig zusammenkriege.
Wir hatten irgendeine Wartungsrunde.
So, Weekly Wartungsrunde und jemand aus meinem Team damals, also ein Kollege von mir, hatte einen Change eingestellt.
So, ich habe den Change in der Wartungsrunde angekündigt, weil es mussten ja nicht alle Leute, selbst ich habe den Change in der Wartungsrunde angekündigt.
So und dann kam dann einer dieser Leute, die immer nerven mussten um die Ecke und meinten dann so
Ja, also ich hab gesehen, dieser Change, der findet ja um irgendwie 1 Uhr nachts statt und das ist aus seiner Sicht ja auch ein sehr kritischer Change.
Habt ihr dann auch sichergestellt, dass jemand von der Qualitätssicherung nachts da ist und das dann direkt mal kurz testen kann?
Und ich sagte, ne, das haben wir nicht sichergestellt, wir sind nicht für Personalplanung der Qualitätssicherung zuständig, das ist unter anderem eines der Gründe, warum es diese Change-Runde gibt, dass wenn es noch zusätzliche Anforderungen an extra Leute gibt, dass das dann vom Change-Management und unter anderem halt auch demjenigen, der es gesagt hat, übernommen wird.
Und dann meinte der Typ so zu mir, also das war ein Change-Manager, ja, der hätte eigentlich dann hingehen müssen und sagen, ja, ich hätte gern jemand dabei, hätte zum Betriebsrat gehen müssen und fragen dürfen die Nachtseinsatz machen, das wäre eigentlich seine Aufgabe gewesen, ne.
Und dann meinte er so, ne, das wäre nicht seine Aufgabe, wir sollen doch mal jemand von der Qualitätssicherung fragen und dann auf ihn zukommen.
Und da haben wir uns da auch bestimmt 10 Minuten rumgezankt, dass das nicht die Aufgabe dessen
ist, der die Technik macht.
Also wie gesagt, der Change an sich war ja gar nicht von uns, wir hatten nur einen Part
in diesem Change, nämlich, ich glaube es war sogar ein Kubernetes Cluster Upgrade,
dass wir in den Webinterface in Azure dreimal klicken und warten bis es durch ist, ich glaube
war sogar ein kubernetes update und das ist das ist nicht unser change wir haben wir haben einen
teil dieses changes und den stelle ich jetzt vor das ist das upgrade des kubernetes clusters
und wenn change management sagt wir brauchen leute dazu ja dann macht doch das ist dann macht doch
ich meine ich habe sie doch jetzt gesagt du bist change manager wir sind in der change rolle dann
fragt die doch. Nein, nein, das ist nicht meine Aufgabe. Kümmert euch doch mal drum,
dass wir jemand von der Qualitätssicherung beibekommen und dann sollen wir auf ihn zukommen.
Da hab ich gesagt, nö, mach ich net. Da haben wir uns richtig 10 Minuten in den Haaren gehabt.
Und das war so witzig im Nachhinein, weil mich haben sogar Leute nebenbei, also von
diesem Change-Manager, der keine Changes managen will, das hab ja nicht ich gesagt, während
wir da diskutiert haben, haben mich noch zwei, drei Leute oder sowas angeschrieben im Teams
und haben mehr oder weniger das gleiche geschrieben.
So, lol, wo sind wir denn hier gelandet, alter?
Change Manager, der keine Changes managen will.
Das war komplett unabhängig davon, ja?
Und es wurde folgendermaßen dann geregelt, es wurde folgendermaßen dann geregelt, ein
anderer Change Manager, der eigentlich für den Bereich gar nicht so richtig zuständig
der aber auch in der Wartungsrunde war, der die Wartungsrunde quasi geleitet hat,
hat gesagt, wisst ihr was? Wir machen das so, ich gucke mir das Ticket nachher mal an
und lade die Beteiligten ein. Fertig. Das musste irgendjemand anderes machen.
Aber der andere Typ, der exakt, wirklich genau dafür da war, so was zu machen,
wollte einfach nicht. Und ich hab's nicht eingesehen zum damaligen Zeitpunkt,
Dass man sich als jemand, der quasi nur einen Teil, der sagen wir mal einen der technischen Parts von dem Gesamt-Change durchführt,
dass der auf einmal verantwortlich dafür sein soll, dass Tester einen Nachteinsatz machen.
Das ist nicht, dass wir, eines Technikers, der nachts einen Change macht, sich um den kompletten Change-Ablauf zu kümmern.
Der ist dafür da, seinen Teil ordentlich zu planen, vorzubereiten, zu dokumentieren, anzukündigen und sonst nix.
Ich mein, dafür hast du ja Leute, die sich explizit um diesen Change-Prozess kümmern.
Ja, also das war witzig, der Change-Manager, der keine Changes managen wollte, ja?
Das ist, das, das war auch so ein Kandidat, Alter, ich sag euch, mit, äh...
Das war auch so einer, da hast du das Gefühl, der hat immer nur was gesagt, um sich mal wieder ins Gespräch zu bringen.
Ähm, bei euch auf der Arbeit gibt es einen Admin, der sich nicht auf die Server einloggen
will.
Was administriert er denn eigentlich, wenn er sich nicht auf den Servern einloggen will?
Also ist ein Admin, ohne sich auf Servern einzuhalten, eigentlich ein Admin?
Potato Bob, ich hab Potato Cop gelesen erst.
Potato Bob schreibt, ist wie unser Anforderungsmanager, der die Antworten immer ungefragt an die Entwickler
gibt, damit das einfach, ja das ist auch geil.
Ich denke mir halt in so einer Position, dass der nicht alles alleine wissen und machen
Und schreiben kann verstehe ich ja aber dann soll er sich halt mal ein paar leute ich meine viele in dieser position vergessen dass manager
Oftmals ja gar nicht heißt dass sie es selber machen müssen sondern dass sie managen müssen unter anderem dass die richtigen leute zusammenkommen
Manager bedeutet ja oftmals nicht mache den scheiß selber
Sondern besorgt er die leute und bringen die leute an einen tisch die wissen was sie machen
Und im zweifelsfall schreibt dann halt das ergebnis zusammen ja oder lasst ihr die teile liefern und schreibt schöne schöne
Gesamtkunstwerk da draus, weil ansonsten, wenn ein Manager nicht managt, da brauchst du ihn ja auch
nicht. Und dafür ist der Manager da. Du brauchst auch keinen Teamleiter, wenn er das, oder kein
Team, ja, Gruppenmanager, Gruppenleiter, wie auch immer es sei, wenn er das Team nicht vertritt. Wenn
er einfach nur da ist, dann brauchst du ihn nicht. Da muss das Team vertreten, sowohl gegenüber dem
Team die Entscheidung von oben umgedreht, aber auch wenn es Probleme gibt, nach oben und einem nach Möglichkeit halt
auch den Rücken frei halten, wenn es um irgendwelche Entscheidungen geht, dass man nicht selbst
Dinge machen muss, die man vielleicht gar nicht machen darf und sowas. Da muss ich sagen, da hatte ich tatsächlich fast immer Glück.
Also mein letzter, auch mein aktueller Chef, also
der aktuelle, beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber, aber auch die davor, die waren tatsächlich alle nicht übel.
Mein aktueller Chef hat vielleicht einen, zumindest muss ich mich da noch dran gewöhnen,
vielleicht einen kleinen, so ein bisschen zu sehr Hands-Off-Approach, ich weiß nicht
wie man das sonst nennen mag, aber der hat halt auch sehr viele Leute, also von dem kriegt
man sehr wenig mit.
Der mietet eigentlich den ganzen Tag und man sieht den hauptsächlich in, ja, zweimal in
der Teamrunde, so nach dem Motto, ähm, ja gut, und klar, man kann ja im Teams anschreiben
Und meistens meldet er sich dann auch, aber ansonsten kriegt man nicht viel mit, man muss sich seine Arbeit mehr oder weniger selbst organisieren.
Was ich auch eigentlich ganz gut finde, aber
ich weiß nur, ab und zu mal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr mitkriegen könnte man schon.
Auf der anderen Seite ist auch gut, ja, dass man machen kann, was man will. Ich weiß nicht, es ist alles so eine Sache, aber
ich krieg glaube ich demnächst bald einen neuen Chef.
Ähm, ja. Aber da kann ich jetzt nicht zu viel erzählen, weil intern ist Zeug.
Aber Leute, es gibt immer was zu meckern, ja? Also, insgesamt kann ich mich aber echt nicht beschweren.
Also sowohl bei meinem aktuellen Chef, als auch bei den letzten, die haben sich alle Mühe gegeben.
Wo ich echt Probleme hatte, ist damals beim Provider mit meinem Chef und beim alten Arbeitgeber mit den ersten paar, die ich da hatte.
Also da hatte ich wirklich Probleme, aber die letzten paar Jahre über haben sich eigentlich alle Mühe gegeben.
Was ihnen teilweise sogar zum Verhängnis geworden ist.
Also einer meiner ehemaligen Chefs wurde ja quasi gekickt für zu oft Widerspruch.
Der hat das halt wirklich vertreten, was man ihm gesagt hat.
gesagt hat, so nach dem Motto, was Probleme macht und was trotz Ankündigung nicht besser
geworden ist, das hat er dann auch immer so erzählt und wahrscheinlich ist ihm das zum
Verhängnis geworden.
Und da hat er dann auch gesagt, ich weiß, also einen meiner ehemaligen Chefs haben sie
ja wirklich rausgeekelt aus der Firma und eines der Gründe dafür muss gewesen sein,
ist so meine Vermutung, dass er halt gesagt hat, dass die Umsetzung von Homeoffice
Ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie ich denke, dass er es gemeint hat. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie er es wirklich gesagt hat.
Also er hat sinngemäß wahrscheinlich sowas gesagt wie, dass die Umsetzung hier in dem Unternehmen
nicht auf sehr viel, nicht auf positive Resonanz bei seinen Leuten stößt.
So, und das muss der wohl auch öfters mal angesprochen haben.
Jedes Mal, wenn, wenn da dran rumgedoktert wurde an den Regelungen,
dass das halt eben nicht gut ankommt.
Und da hat er auch recht, ich mein, das ist eigentlich auch was, was ich erwarten würde
von einem Teamleiter, von einem Gruppenleiter, je nachdem, wie man's nennen mag,
dass der, wenn es so Probleme gibt, dass der das auch schon weitergibt.
Ich mein, wo ist denn der Sinn davon, wenn du alles verschweigst und dann werden ja irgendwie Entscheidungen getroffen, die nichts mit der Realität zu tun haben.
Das kann ja auch nicht sein.
Im umgedrehten Fall, wenn man dann sagt, okay, ja, wir haben gehört, dass das den Leuten nicht gefällt, wir machen es trotzdem, dann muss der das auch genauso verkaufen.
Dann muss der sagen, Leute, ich hab das angebracht, wollen sie nicht, wir müssen das so und so machen.
Vorgabe.
Das musst du als Teamleiter hinkriegen, das musst du in beide Richtungen auf die Reihe kriegen und es müssen dann auch dem seine Vorgesetzten das aushalten, dass der halt mal sagt, was Sache ist.
Und das haben die nicht ausgehalten beim alten Arbeitgeber. Also es wurde einem meiner ehemaligen Chefs zum Verhängnis, dass der sich wohl da auf Veranstaltungen, die Führungskräfte-Meetings,
wohl offen gesagt hat, keiner mag eure Homeoffice-Regelung, die ihr da gerade macht.
Also, das hat er nicht so gesagt, aber er hat das so gemeint, ja.
Und das war halt schlicht ergreifend komplett die Wahrheit.
Und das wurde eben zum Verhängnis, das wollten sie nicht hören.
Und das waren ja nicht nur wir, das waren ja viele Teams.
Weiß nicht, ob er das darf, ja, dann ist er auch kein Admin mehr.
Aktuell ähnliches Problem, Scrum Master will sich nicht um agile Probleme kümmern, die
er verbockt hat.
Kommt drauf an, was das für Probleme sind.
Also der Scrum Master ist ja eigentlich nur dafür da, um, ja gut eigentlich genau für
Sowas so dass diese
Agile Arbeitsweise
Irgendwie etabliert wird gecoacht wird eingehalten wird ich kenne die offizielle Definition davon nicht
Deswegen darf ja eigentlich auch ein Scrum Master kein Projektleiter oder sowas sein
Leider wird das oftmals ein bisschen vermischt was dann wieder keinen Sinn ergibt weil der Projektleiter andere ganz andere Interessen als das Scrum Master hat
Aber ja eigentlich ist das schon ist das schon so ein bisschen die Aufgabe weil manche haben auch zwei Sachen manche haben quasi einen Scrum Master
Und manche haben dann noch zusätzlich einen, jetzt haltet euch fest, einen Agile Coach.
Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr auch schon mal ein Agile Coaching gehabt?
Ich hatte schon mal ein Agiles Coaching.
Und das war gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist, ok, kurz gesagt, das ist ein Typ der da sitzt, meistens von irgendeiner Beraterfirma und weil er schon in so vielen Unternehmen war, die agile Sachen versucht haben einzuführen und zu machen und zu leben, weiß der halt Bescheid und kann einem Ratschläge geben, wenn was nicht gut klappt.
Also, ja, ich hatte schon mal ein Projekt mit einem agilen Code und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das war gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich war ja am Anfang sehr skeptisch der ganzen Sache übereingestellt, weil ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, jetzt haben sie wieder irgendeinen externen Typ hier hingesetzt, der dir sonst was erzählt, was mit den Abläufen hier überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Aber ich muss sagen, das war eines der wenigen Consultants und eines der wenigen so, ähm, wir wollen uns krass verbessern und wir machen jetzt was, wo tatsächlich ganz gut gewesen ist.
Am Ende hat es nichts gebracht, weil nichts von dem, was wir da vorgeschlagen und erarbeitet haben, je gemacht wurde, aber der Typ an sich war nicht verkehrt.
Hi Max, ich bin seit gestern mit meinem Netzwerk-Admin-Kurs fertig.
Die Juniorsteller in meiner Nähe fragen dennoch nach Berufserfahrung, trotzdem...
Klar.
Warum nicht?
Schade und nix.
Warum nicht? Schade doch nix.
Die können sich das aktivieren.
Du hast doch Berufserfahrung, wenn du erst
wenn du First und Second Level
Support machst.
Du hast doch Berufserfahrung.
Berufserfahrung heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig,
dass du Erfahrung haben musst,
in exakt 100% Match,
was die haben wollen.
Darfst du den Consult nennen?
Ich wüsste nicht, warum ich ihn nicht nennen darf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den nennen will.
Und ich weiß aus dem Kopf auch gar nicht mehr, wie diese Consulting-Klitsche überhaupt hieß.
Also...
Du hast doch Berufserfahrung.
Das ja.
Also ich würde mich auf jeden Fall bewerben, wenn das was ist, was du machen willst.
Und ich kann dir sagen,
viele Unternehmen sind aktuell auch nicht sonderlich wählerisch.
Was gut ist auch, weil ich bin eh der Meinung, dass sie oftmals ein bisschen zu sehr aussortieren, weil es ist gar nicht so wichtig, dass die Leute so 100% darauf passen, es ist wichtig, dass es ein Thema ist, was die Leute irgendwie begeistert und dass die einarbeitungswillig sind und Bock drauf haben.
Das ist eigentlich fast das Wichtigste.
Also ich würde beispielsweise auch eine Netzwerkadmin einstellen, wenn der mir sagt, ich hab die
letzten 15 Jahre Cisco gemacht, aber wir machen irgendeinen anderen Hersteller.
Also das kriegt der schon hin mit der Zeit.
Also ich würde das machen.
Und nachdem die aktuell eh nicht so wählerisch sind, wenn du gut passt, sollen sie dich einarbeiten,
Was auf jeden Fall unterm Strich angenehmer ist, als jemand, der alles 100% kann, aber mit dem man nicht auskommt.
Ring erinnern? Exzellent. Ich muss auch gleich ins Bett.
Exzellent.
Woher das agile Gerede kommt, weil das seit ein paar Jahren so ein Trend ist, dass alle
agil sein wollen und ich glaube kaum einer von denen hat sich mal dieses agile Manifest,
was es seit Jahrzehnten schon gibt, auch nur die ersten paar Dinge angeguckt und wenn das
nicht, ich muss sagen, groß gelesen habe ich das auch nicht, es gibt aber einen Vortrag
da drüber, von einem der Mitunterzeichner dieser ganzen ursprünglichen Sache, und der
lässt kein gutes Haar an, was aktuell diese Agile-Geschichte geworden ist.
Also eines der ursprünglichen Gedanken hinter dieser ganzen Agilität-Sache ist ja, dass
sich Programmierer weniger mit Managern auseinandersetzen müssen.
Das ist eines der zentralen Gedanken schlechthin.
Also dieses, wir machen agil in der Administration und sowas, ergibt eigentlich kaum einen Sinn, zumindest nach der ursprünglichen Idee.
Also eines der zentralen Sachen von dieser ursprünglichen agilen Idee, sagt auch einer der ursprünglichen Unterzeichner selbst, war, dass sich Programmierer weniger mit Manager diskutieren müssen.
Um Manager aus der täglichen Programmierarbeit rauszuhalten.
Das war eines der ursprünglichen Gedanken davon.
Und daher kommt ja auch das mit Sprints und sowas, so nach dem Motto, ok, Product Owner und Manager und hast du nicht gesehen, die können alle, was weiß ich, alle 14 Tage, alle 2 Monate, wie auch immer, zusammensetzen und das Projekt steuern.
Aber das Umsetzen der Aufgaben dann in diesem Sprint, das dürfen die Programmierer selbst
organisieren.
Also nichts mehr mit täglichem Statusbericht beim Chef und bei Daily Meetings Projektmanager
dabei, der sagt, ah das und das hier müssen wir jetzt noch anpassen und das und das heute
ist wichtig.
Also das war eines der ursprünglichen Gedanken hinter dieser ganzen Agile Geschichte.
Es gibt zig Methoden davon mittlerweile.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich halte von den wenigsten dieser ganzen Frameworks oder auch Zertifizierungen und sowas,
was es muss zum jeweiligen Unternehmen passen.
Man kann sich sicherlich irgendwelche Frameworks nehmen und daraus sich das raussuchen, was gut passt.
Man sollte allerdings nicht auf die Idee kommen, man muss jetzt den kompletten Laden umstricken, was eh nicht geht.
geht, ja weil es meistens nur einzelne Projekte sind, um das alles hundertprozentig zu erfüllen.
Das muss, das muss passen.
Ja, da hört es bei ein paar vielen schon auf.
So nach dem Motto, da kann dann das Management verkaufen.
Wir sind super agil, wir haben jetzt agile Methodik eingeführt. Ja, was macht ihr denn?
Äh...
Wir haben 5 Jira-Tickets.
Ha ha ha ha ha...
Die wenigsten machen das, äh, nach der...
Ich muss jetzt mal sagen, was heißt die wenigsten.
Ich muss sagen, bei keinem, wo ich bisher gewesen bin...
hat man es geschafft, die ursprüngliche Idee hinter dieser ganzen agilen Geschichte einzuführen bzw. zu etablieren.
Man hat irgendwas versucht zu machen, weil agil jeder macht und agil cool klingt
und dann kam im Endeffekt irgendwas raus, was eigentlich mehr oder weniger so ist wie immer,
Nur dass es jetzt agil heißt
Ja und das das sieht man zum beispiel schon daran wenn man auf die idee kommt das kram master ist gleichzeitig auch im projektmanagement
Das widerspricht sich einfach grundsätzlich das kann wenn man das richtig machen will gar nicht funktionieren das ergibt keinen sinn
Aber wird oftmals gemacht
Da muss ich sagen tatsächlich bei meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber das ist ja also ich bin ja da auch zum größten teil in
in einem Projekt unterwegs, wo es tatsächlich um Blockchain-Technologie geht.
Ja gut, nach fünf Jahren Handel hat das jetzt eine Versicherung auch mal mitbekommen,
dass das was cooles ist. Das dauert immer ein bisschen, so in der Finanzbranche, die sind ja nicht so schnell.
Und die geben sich tatsächlich Mühe,
das nicht so einfach nur agil zu branden, sondern
Sie versuchen das wirklich in irgendeiner Art und Weise mit Sprints und Einteilen und so und auch der Manager oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der Projektmanager ist, die geben sich tatsächlich Mühe.
Das Problem ist nur, dass es auch nur beschränkt hilft, wenn ein Projekt jetzt möglichst agil
sein will, aber alles andere drumherum ist Oldschool-Finanzbranche-as-fuck mit dreifachen
Durchschlägen und 100 Genehmigungen.
Also sobald du nicht mehr das rein Projekt intern handeln kannst, wird das eh nix mit
Agilität in dem Fall. Und wir können halt sehr vieles nicht projektintern
handeln
Weil ja
Das halt einfach nicht unser Bier ist
Aber sie geben sich zumindest Mühe. Sie geben sich mehr Mühe als davor
Bei der alten Kiste. So, wieso noch wach? Leute, ich muss jetzt ins Bett, morgen früh wieder aufstehen
Wir sehen uns und dann morgen müssen wir uns echt mal die Apples zusammenfassen und angucken. Das habe ich heute nicht mal auf die Reihe gekriegt
Macht's gut, bis dann, tschau.